oh hey I didn't see you there I was just
enjoying one of my favorite thing
hobbies things reading fan fictions so
that's why
thanks to my buddies over at Mountain
Dew we're hosting a fan fiction contest
yay fan fictions in general just makes
me feel like oh so it makes perfect
sense for me to do this we had some
great funds with fan fictions before of
course fields of course and I want you
bros to submit your fan fictions to me
so we can make more of the love happen
in the joy of words submissions are open
from today to the 30th of January 2015
so what's really awesome about it it's
that this contest is open for
international residents which means that
any one of you brothers can participate
no matter where you live but to submit
you need to be 18 or older or age of
majority in your country to submit your
fan fiction you need to go to PT Polycom
slash fan fiction there you'll find more
info on the whole thing
but the basic idea is that you choose
from three different categories action
comedy or horror should be pretty
interesting you can add any guest talent
or props that you can find in the list
from the submission portal but there are
two rules you cannot go beyond 500 words
and you can only submit 5 fan fictions
per person I think that's quite enough
how many fan fictions can one person
produce ok
so 5 is the limit that's the rule
now for the price three fan fiction
stories will be selected and they will
be animated for my channel so that's
pretty awesome
you basically have golden opportunity to
troll the hell out of me now please take
this chance press
I mean don't wait what so yeah just go
to peopie dot-com / fan fiction to
submit you can find all the rules and
all the information that you need over
there like I said you can be from
anywhere in the world and the contest
lasts until the 30th of January 2015 the
episode should be ready sometime in May
yeah that's all you need to know now go
ride me some good old stuff
make me proud bros I know you will I'm
very excited for this I think it'll be a
lot of fun and yeah we'll see what you
boys come up with that's all for me for
now thank you for watching and as always
stay awesome bros